it's as bad as it gets now thousands
upon thousands trapped behind them the
taliban in front soldiers having to
decide who stays and who goes
nobody planned this it's just how it is
the hours are counting down and they
know it there are no good options left
to them stick this out try to get the
family through and onto a flight but
risk failure
or go home and await whatever may happen
at the hands of their new masters
and hope it's not fatal
this is absolutely awful
such as the desperation to be heard by
the soldiers the would-be evacuees are
standing up to their knees in a
sewage-filled canal
the stench is indescribable
some have been here for days remember
the heat the lack of water the lack of
food and the conditions they're in are a
cocktail just as lethal as any bullet
when they can identify people with the
right papers to travel they're pulled
from the canal
it's a deep and sheer wall the soldiers
and the strongest stooping down to grab
their families often huge extended
families and out of the water
they emerged dripping wet but relieved
that nightmare is over it still however
doesn't mean it's about to get any
easier
this is just the point where their right
to travel will be considered
they can still be rejected
the numbers of tiny children enduring
all this is heartbreaking it must be so
so scary it's noisy here there are
gunshots and shouting the whole time
what does this little boy think sat in
his father's arms protected from the sun
by an umbrella an occasional stroke to
comfort him
that's all his dad can do really just
comfort him
well there's a real sense now that
people beginning to expect that this
whole airlift is coming to an end and
they're really really desperate i mean
they're in a
sewage canal they're trying to show
their paperwork trying to show that they
perhaps should be looked at
it's really desperate that is actually
the sort of pretty much hopeless column
we're told but i can see all sorts of
passports from different countries
the fact is that
when the withdrawal happens
it's always going to be difficult
because they can't keep working the
soldiers can't keep working up until the
last minute they have to start
withdrawing in the days leading up to
their departure
how they're going to deal with these
people when that happens we just don't
know
the taliban are relieving the pressure
on the process because they're stopping
people coming now
those aren't foreign special forces
that's the taliban special forces more
heavily armed than others and now slowly
taking control of the paras processing
point
beyond the british lines they direct the
human traffic from above
there's no choice for the soldiers this
is the only way things can get done
and the soldiers are absolutely
exhausted inside the walls of the
compound they grab a few hours rest they
aren't working shifts these boys have
done two days and nights in a row
they're absolutely wiped out
they'll be back on the barricades in a
few minutes
they will never forget this strange
unexpected tour of duty
a lot has happened in a short period of
time
um but
people have sort of risen to the
challenge accepted what's been put in
front of them and we really focused on
the importance of recovering the
entitled personnel doing their mission
and doing it for a good cause and and of
course your soldiers are very young a
lot of them right this is not something
they're probably ever expected to do no
i think that's a fair comment for many
people at any age not many of them have
seen scenes such as this
but again driven by that real sense of
purpose um they've actually absolutely
been committed to the task
and we'll see it through to the end
and so this process goes on it matters
what is discussed and agreed thousands
of miles away but until someone says
it's over they'll keep trying and keep
hoping
that's all they have left
mr ramsey sky news cobble